the queen has said that she is irritated
by the lack of progress on climate
change ahead of the cop 26 climate
change summit it's just over two weeks
until world leaders are due to meet in
glasgow to try to reach agreement on
cutting greenhouse gas emissions the 95
year old monarch was heard making the
comments at the opening of the senate in
wales
[Music]
[Music]
i speak to our royal correspondent
rihanna standing by for us this morning
hi we are on third royal in a week to
have a view on climate change
yeah it seems that they are all wading
in this week but i have to say it's not
surprising to hear from the likes of
prince william or prince charles but
certainly unexpected to hear these words
from her majesty the queen of course
during her reign she is notoriously
quiet when it comes to her own private
thoughts
especially when it comes to big
important occasions like cop which as
you say is coming up
in just a couple of weeks the fact that
these comments also were made in a
public space so she had literally just
opened
the welsh parliament she was then having
this conversation with ellen jones who
is the presiding officer
and also her daughter-in-law the duchess
of cornwall a very animated conversation
where she then said well we've been
hearing all about cop but we don't
exactly know who's coming yet and then
made those words saying how irritating
it is when world leaders talk but they
don't do now it is so rare to hear the
queen speaking in these kind of terms i
think the last time uh we heard her make
this kind of slip up if you like was
when she criticized at the chinese
following the chinese state visit she
made those comments at a garden party
but she is often very careful
with what she says why does it matter
what she says as head of state of course
she will not be sitting down
during those negotiations at cop but she
will be playing a very important role
when she opened the scottish parliament
a couple of weeks ago she talked about
how important it is to see britain on
the world stage hosting that important
climate conference and when the
conference gets underway she'll be
hosting a very important reception on
that first day she'll be welcoming all
of those leaders so i suspect a bit of
frustration that she doesn't know
exactly who she's going to be meeting
but also i think for the government
really important for the queen to be
setting that welcoming tone um so i'm
not sure that her comments are
necessarily that helpful uh criticizing
those world leaders with uh so little
time to go until the start of that
conference